so Kirishima is unbreakable form finally
made its debut in the anime and today
we're gonna examine just how strong it
actually is so just as a warning in
order to do this we're gonna have to
cover some content that hasn't yet been
seen in the anime - if you really want
to avoid any spoiler then I would advise
just going on my channel and checking
out some of the other spoiler free stuff
that I have
okay so unbreakable is cure chimas new
super move and it was partly the result
of the extensive training he did before
they hear a licensing exam but also due
to the fact that all my gave him a bit
of cool advice and people say oh my
isn't a good teacher come on guys give
the man his credit but before we fully
examine unbreakable however let's just
lay the groundwork regarding his quirk
although you probably already know this
so as I'm sure you're aware his base
quirk allows him to harden his body into
a state that is not only strong enough
to deflect bullets but is arguably
tougher than steel given that he was
evenly matched in a fight against this
maniac the areas that he hardens become
very jagged which is why his first name
when written in Japanese contains the
kanji for cut and for sharp his base
quirk is also good for close combat
although there is a limit to how long he
can remain hardened which is kind of
what we saw in the sports festival when
he was fighting back ago he was in that
fight worn down
despite this by nature his quirk does
favour a more defensive fighting style
as he's essentially explosion-proof and
bulletproof was his quirk is active but
let's move on to the reason why you
clicked on this video how strong is
unbreakable
so red riah unbreakable takes his quirk
to a new level and as we saw in the
anime he can literally harden every
crevice of his entire body that includes
his eyes his teeth his hair and whatever
he's got going on in his pants as well
and the main benefit of this move is
that not only is it significantly harder
but he essentially becomes
indestructible at least for about a
minute this means that he can nullify
virtually any attack that's thrown at
him
in fact I reckon he could probably
withstand a punch or two from this guy
and we saw this demonstrated in the show
when that villain was easily pissing his
skin before he used unbreakable butt and
once he turned on unbreakable suddenly
that villain couldn't even touch him and
whilst he can't hold it for too long
right now remember that Kirishima is
still a first-year students so so by the
time he graduates I reckon he could
probably have it up to about 10 minute
so more and unlike his usual form this
unbreakable mode should not wear off
based on the number of hits he's taken
at least that's what we thought those of
you who have read even further in the
manga will know that this form was
pretty effortlessly destroyed by rapper
in one of the best fights of the overall
arc and for me this kind of took away
the amazement as seeing unbreakable for
the first time because it kind of hurts
to see it be destroyed so easily but to
kill regime is credit he did still put
up one hell of a fight by continuously
reharden himself after getting worn down
but the fact remains that unbreakable
was still beaten down by rapper and
let's be real here rapper is a strong
villain but he is by far by far is not
nowhere close to being the strongest
villain we've seen in my ear academia so
if he can do that imagine what an actual
boss villain could do and then we have
to move on to the joint training art
with class one be your Ashima in this
arc was again taken out quite quickly
despite being in unbreakable mode this
guy from class 1b whose name I don't
actually know basically just picture
Shima and threw him up in the air and I
know the quirk is called unbreakable not
on throwable but still the fact that he
can just pick up Kirishima and not start
bleeding because remember unbreakable is
super jagged so the fact that he wasn't
like wow this hurts or or wasn't
bleeding or anything like that it just
made it seem like unbreakable didn't do
anything and then of course after he
threw Kirishima in the air a barra of
class 1b just use her vine quirk to kind
of like wrap Kirishima up and throw him
in the cages so during that whole
interaction whether he was in
unbreakable mode or just using his
normal hardening it didn't really make a
single difference so whilst this super
move does have many advantages people
with quirks that allow for long distance
attacks or someone like rapper or Deku
whose attacks can just be relentless
unbreakable can be worn down I came
across a reddit post that definitely
resonated with my thought process it
said that Kirishima squark makes his
fighting ability very situational so if
an enemy is out of range or if the
battle is going on too long he's just
not able to keep up and while we all
love Kirishima
I gotta say that if I was gonna give his
unbreakable move a rating out of 10 at
this point I would have to give it a 6
point 9 like it's above average for sure
but it needs more practical applications
it's just too situational like the
conditions have to be right as they were
in episode 5 of season 4
or for it to you know stand out but
anyway that's just my opinion let me
know what you think I'm unbreakable am I
being overly harsh here and that my
friends was us examining how strong red
Riot unbreakable is and before you go be
sure to check out my my villain academia
explainer video is one of my favorite
videos that I've ever done and subscribe
for more my her academia videos as I'm
aiming for 500 subs by the end of 2019
peace